gentlemen good to see you both you as
well how are you
i'm good andy i have to say um i was
half expecting you to wear a more dale
like
shirt today i was kind of hoping
like you know
i was doing my best approximation for
you i feel like yours looks good and now
i feel like a square
well i mean we'll try
next time for the sequel we'll come out
and come back around for the sequel
there's a lot of sequel talk i'm
enjoying that i think we got to turn
this we got to flip this thing
well we've been waiting 30 years you
don't want to go for just one right
completely agree yes
so why like of all like the disney
afternoon
lineup andy for you why chip and dale
why chip and dale's rescue rangers for
me i chose chip and dale specifically
because it was the movie akiva was
already making and that's how i decided
yeah
that is an interesting interesting way
to go that's how i choose
yeah me i work at disney i run disney i
took over for bob iger and i was just
looking through all our properties and
you know this one really stuck out at a
soft spot from you know watching it as a
kid and when i took over disney i was
like well let's look at let's see what
we got in the old vault
yeah and you open up that disney evolve
and you're like here we go i have
opportunity yeah there's not a lot in
there because they put it all on disney
plus
screaming now for seven nights anything
left in the vault was rescue rangers
you're like that's the one thing that
was in there i you get to play around
with a lot of disney characters and like
in my mind a lot of these characters are
kind of sacred but to do a lot of like
interesting and fun things with them was
there a point where you're like whoa i
can't believe they're letting us do this
uh throughout even just developing the
script with the writers we were like are
they really gonna let us do this and
every day
you know we would put something in
into the storyboards the animatics into
the animation and then disney would see
it and sometimes they wouldn't say
anything and sometimes they'd go okay
you can't cross the line there maybe
pull that back or they'd say
uh you're not allowed to use that
character let's let's look for somebody
else so it was a constant
uh conversation
[Music]
who was a character that you would have
loved to have been able to include in
this that's uh that didn't get the shine
in this one
i mean you would have probably guessed
this if i just was like who do you think
but stan the dog from dog with a blog
that was probably the number one
choice i was trying to get in there um
he's a dog he's technically a
live-action hybrid much like the whole
film he's a live-action dog but with an
animated mouth so he would be kind of in
one character
encapsulating the whole
the whole film
yeah andy there's there's a there's a
lot of mods to uh
the things like specifically who framed
roger rabbit in this even even
thematically like is was that
part of the draw to this you're kind of
doing
almost a modern take on that
i mean certainly akiva and i would say
were
people that grew up as kids loving roger
rabbit
like not
just the movie but also the dance
um and
i mean like i had a gigantic roger who
fan roger rabbit t-shirt that was
clearly not my size but i wore the hell
out of it until it fell apart and became
tatters
so i think
given the opportunity to make something
in that vein you know and that fun genre
mash up and
just remembering how it felt as a kid to
watch that and have your mind blown of
like wait a minute so the cartoons are
in our world and just loving that so
much and thinking about making something
like that for kids now
was exciting for sure
so for your money both you guys when you
were young what was like the disney
afternoon lineup that for you was like
the best four
cartoons to watch in a row
i mean ducktales
a lot of ducktales chip and dale rescue
rangers obviously
uh i was saying i don't know andy if you
had this experience but darkwing duck i
always liked but i always missed it like
i don't because the the the animation
block of the disney afternoon would
shuffle the order
i never knew which ones you were we were
gonna get to see and for whatever reason
darkwing whatever slot it fell into i
felt like it was like
very special and rare when i got to see
one i don't have any idea why in
hindsight yeah i would definitely say
rescue rangers and ducktales were the
ones i saw the most for whatever my end
of school dinner time schedule however
that landed and gummy bears for whatever
reason was constantly i feel like i
might have saw more gummy bears than
ever anything else but i don't know why
it's week weekdays i feel like i watched
it on saturday mornings well maybe
that's why maybe i knew when it was on
but it was also part there technically
part of the disney afternoon family
really
yeah i watched you i mean he would know
he would know yeah guys uh i had a ton
of fun watching this movie it was
awesome to like revisit all those
characters thanks for the time all the
best seeing your in your best deal shirt
next time
i'll bring it trust i'll bring it next
time
you